my name is Jeffrey bellman visual
effects supervisor for Black Panther our
job kind of I think involves from the
beginning stages of pre-production all
the way through post early on my jobs to
sit with the director in the studio and
kind of listen to the process as the
creative ideas change and then advise as
far as how we might shoot the ideas
creating a world that Ryan had
envisioned was probably the biggest
biggest challenge the world that no one
has ever seen before but that still
feels a part of this earth so trying to
create a futuristic city that is what
Conda or the Golden City and makanda
that you could feel is you know a few
flights away what do you know anytime
there is an environment it is I would
say 99% of time based off of a location
that we found in Africa and we're able
to photograph and capture I always find
visual effects are best if you can base
them off of some type of reality
I think that you're really in for a
treat to go in there and actually all of
a sudden have the screen open up and
that I think coupled with all the sound
is it really gonna be a fun fun journey
it's gonna be a ride I think the last
part that you'll you'll really enjoy is
when you're kind of flying into Wakanda
as well to get a better scope and scale
of the city by opening it up oh yeah
home there's definitely a lot of fun to
be had in the IMAX
[Music]